je préfère si tu veux vivre une vie très
intense même si je dois mourir jeune que
de de de mourir à 80 ou 90 ans euh en
ayant euh le sentiment d'avoir rien fait
de ma
vie il est moins connu du grand public
que Patrick etlinget ou Catherine
destivel il est pourtant le plus grand
spécialiste mondial de sa catégorie
l'escalade en solo comprenait sans
cordes ni baudrier il s'appelle Alain
Robert il détient depuis peu le record
mondial de difficultés les chutes qui
ont é et sa carrière ne l'empêche pas de
continuer portrait d'un acharné par
Pascal dousébon et Stéphane
[Musique]
poule grimper en solo c'est intéressant
parce que bon c'est la liberté
par-dessus tout aucune contrainte
matériel juste moi et le
rocher il est le meilleur tout
simplement à 31 ans Alain Robert a déjà
grimpé en solo des voies de niveau 8b
les spécialistes apprécieront pour les
autres sachez qu'il s'agit d'un exploit
inégalé alain a payé très cher cette
gloire naissante il est déjà tomberé
trois fois lors d'escalade pourtant
facile qui n'ont fait qu'alimenter la
controverse sur les risques de
l'escalade en solo sans corde ni
baudrier je pense que je suis marginal
déjà parce que bon effectivement parce
que je grimpe sans cordes donc il y a
c'est quand même quelque chose qui est
tabou le tabou c'est la mort qu'on
pousse qu'avec des heures et des heures
d'entraînement certains disent àin
suicidaire lui prétend le contraire il
n'a que sa passion à le reposer celle
d'un fou de la vie et non pas d'un
trompe la mort pour moi le SK aun solo
c'est déjà avant tout un désir de vivre
donc c'est paradoxal je sais que bon je
prends des risques de toute façon la
mort peut peut être là à tout moment
mais j'ai surtout envie de vivre et bon
de vivre longtemps déjà parce que j'ai
des gamins j'ai une femme et bon on vit
dans une cellule familiale où tout tout
se passe bien
et à partir de là ben il faut que ça
continue voilà ramène la cellule
familiale c'est Nicole sa femme Hugo 3
ans et Julien 5 ans déjà grimpeur le
défi d'alin est aussi celui des siens
qu'il le veuilleent ou non je lui
interdis pas parce que bon c'est sa vie
aussi hein j'ai pas
le c'est pas mon but
de qu'il arrête sa passion mais bon je
CNE pas du tout ce qu'il
fait c'est clair mais il continuera
quand même c'est son choix celui de
suspendre sa vie là-haut loin au-dessus
de nos
[Musique]
têtes moi l'escalade c'est une passion
en fait qui a démarré il y a
pratiquement une vingtaine d'années et
ce qui m'a intéressé dans l'aspect
escalade c'est l'engagement physique
d'abord et puis surtout le psychologique
c'est quelque chose où il doit y avoir
une notion d'aventure donc de danger
cette soif ce besoin vital de sensations
extrêmes est le moteur de ce grimpeur
solitaire à 31 ans Alain Robert possède
le meilleur palmarès mondial en solo
avec plus de 15 voix côté les plus
difficiles au monde sans cordes et sans
filet par la force des doigts et une
farouche volonté d'atteindre les
[Musique]
sommets quand tu grimpes en fait tu es
concentré sur les prises de place ni
pour le vide ni pour la peur si tu
commences à baliser c'est que ça
commence à devenir
grave le risque je pense que ça peut se
gérer un petit peu par contre on peut
pas dire je suis sûr de moi à 100 % dans
le sens où un ppin peut toujours arriver
une prise qui casse en solo chaque
erreur imprécision manque de chance ou
de concentration est fatale victime de
deux accidents très graves alain Robert
grimpe aujourd'hui avec une invalidité
estimée à 66% des poignets et de la
jambe gauche on est tous né pour pour
mourir un jour et bon je préfère si tu
veux vivre une vie très intense même si
je dois mourir jeune que de de mourir à
80 ou 90 ans en ayant le sentiment
d'avoir rien fait de ma vie rien ni
personne ne peut le stopper dans son
irrésistible ascension pas même sa femme
et ses deux petits garçons chez les
roberts les escaliers sont facultatifs
le grenier lui est impératif c'est sous
les toits de son appartement de balance
qu'alin s'entraîne plusieurs fois par
jour là il répète inlassablement les
prises on se laisse temps pour durcir le
jeu un jeu risqué qui coûte cher et qui
ne rapporte pas forcément gros c'est
difficile hein d'en vivre bon moi je
suis constamment à la recherche de
sponsor c'est d'autant plus difficile
d'ailleurs j'utilise aucun matériel
puisque je suis je suis grimpeur solo
et bon quelque part il y a bon il y a un
petit peu ce sentiment d'injustice par
rapport
à l'engagement de l'activité au danger
que ça peut représenter et le maigre
pactol qu'on peut gagner à travers
l'escalade par rapport par exemple à des
sports médiatiques comme le football où
il y a pas
d'engagement alors pour vivre Alain
travaille à mi-temps dans un magasin de
sport où ses conseils sont dors du
momentùù tuas un chausson très souple il
adhère très très bien sur le rocher et
ce qui fait que ça peut pardonner pas
mal de fautes mais la vente n'est pas sa
passion les chaussons et les bâtons lui
donnent le vertige Robert n'est vraiment
lui-même que lorsqu'il défie les lois de
l'équilibre suspendu à son plafond ou à
ses falaises moins médiatique que
Patrick etedelinger ù Isabelle pâtissier
Robert leedomoi et pourtant la référence
actuelle dans les milieux spécialisés du
monde entier son dernier film intitulé
passion vitale vient d'être primé à de
nombreux festivals en France et à
l'étranger il construit actuellement un
nouveau rêve gravir une voix mythique
sur chacun des cinq continents alors
donc depuis quelques mois il escalade
sous le et la barbe des policiers les
plus haut buildings du monde car il aime
grimper et surtout il aime qu'on parle
de lui génial mgalo al Robert les grand
voyageur se pose sur le ventre
d'une ne respectent pas les consignes ne
font pas de cadeau sinon
solitaire en
souffrance 48 étages à New York 50 à
Chicago et un simple plafond d'escalade
chez lui à Valence c'est ici qu'Alain
Robert se prépare suspendu comme une
araignée il tisse la toile de ses
exploits parî qu' appelle comme ça
Spiderman est-ce qu'il faut être fou
pour faire ce que tu fais je me sens pas
fou du tout tu vois j'ai une
famille
merde la gloire et les ennuis ont
commencé cet été à Chicago sur ce
building de 250 m de haut la City Bank
tower TR qu d'HE d'escalade et une
armada de policier à l'arrivée je me
suis fait arrêter par la les flics en
haut donc il y avit à peu près une
dizaine de personnes des pompiers la
sécurité et
puis donc c'est un petit peu le le
feuilleton policier c'estàdire tout le
monde connaî star ski HCH et bon là
c'est un petit peu comme si j'avais vécu
un feuilleton en direct comment tu te
senta là quand les flics tont passé les
menotes ah ben je me sentais fatigué
déshydraté mais bon j'étais heureux
j'avais réalisé mon objectif
[Musique]
et voilà un je prend des risques
invraisemblables invraiemblable je ne
sais pas s'il va monter jusqu'en
haut quelques semaines plus tard en
septembre c'est autour de la tour de la
Défense à Paris de voir passer cet
étrange visiteur ascension dangereuse et
glissante bon ça s terminé au
commissariat de la défense où j'ai signé
les autographes au flic j'ai eu les
cartes des inspecteurs pour faire sauter
mes PV donc c'est ça était quand même
dans ambi descract alors qu'à New York
par exemple je suis resté 30 HE en
prison arrêté et inculpé pour conduitite
dangereus et violation de domicile
Spider-Man accumule les procès et les
nuits en prison mais rien l'arrête même
à Valence ou pour se dégourdir les
doigts il évite de prendre l'ascenseur
la grosse r ah c'est moins intéressant
c'est moins intéressant que New
York
c'estp recordman du monde de la
difficulté en escalade alainer ne pas
vraiment immeubles sinon en tant que tel
la
réalisation est loin d'être une
performance en janvier il partira faire
le tour du monde des building en
Australie au Japon aux USA avec comme
d'habitude un minimum d'autorisation et
un maximum de
[Musique]
médiia